for the first time we're learning about
test results showing why some trampoline
parks can be so dangerous a Virginia
Virginia engineer says the way many
trampolines are bound together in these
parks can create an unsafe transfer of
energy the number of emergency room
visits from trampoline park injuries
soared to nearly 18,000 in 2017 meg
Oliver has been covering this story for
months
meg good morning good morning to all of
you an engineer is sharing years of
scientific research that showed the
dangers behind the design of some
trampoline parks he's now going public
with his findings for the first time so
how long have you been testing these
trampoline parks for about six years
this crowded basement at Virginia
Commonwealth University is dr. Pete
Petco's lab you can actually see this
moving the biomechanical engineer and
university professor tests trampolines
founded trampoline parks and compares
them to gymnastic trampolines and what
did you find we found there is energy
transferred between trampoline beds it's
really one big trampoline why is that
dangerous because it makes the system
unpredictable the trampoline surface is
changing height have you ever stepped
for a step that isn't their picture
having that happen on a trampoline this
video shows the energy transfer ed in
New Jersey trampoline park add add
double bounces his son and as a result
breaks the child's femur its largest
bone in your body it takes about 900
pounds to break it 900 pounds now he's a
child so say maybe half of that doctor
Petco tests the trampolines with an
impulse hammer and accelerometers to
study the rebound effect he measured how
much force a 220 pound dad could
transfer into his 30 pound son on a
surface that's constantly changing what
we notice is the father transferring
into the son 400 pounds of force Wow
but the bigger number is how fast that
force is actually provided it's like
getting hit with a hammer in this clip
both jumpers are roughly the same size
you have a young man in black he
expected the trampoline to be at one
height it wasn't and he just broke his
ankle you talk trauma surgeon dr. Craig
Cook says he has treated about 100
patients with severe
trampoline park injuries broken legs
spinal fractures and head trauma these
are the type of injuries that we'd see
with high velocity type of trauma motor
vehicle crash you know at 90 miles an
hour the rolls or a motorcycle accident
were victims you know thrown off their
motorcycle and they fly a hundred feet
not all trampoline parks are created
equal Rob Arnold is CEO of launch
trampoline park
the company has 30 parks nationwide with
dozens more under construction you
mentioned that at one of your parks you
did have a neck injury there was a neck
injury yep and does that ever just think
maybe it's just too dangerous no it
doesn't it's like somebody putting on a
pair of skis and going down a down a
mountain you know there's an inherent
risk with what you're doing this New
York City Park which opened last
November says they haven't had any
severe injuries to date
Arnold believes the benefits of jumping
greatly outweigh the risks children with
autism absolutely love the facility we
have kids that have come in obese and
they didn't want to play sports they got
picked on and all they wanted to do is
come to launch Arnold estimates more
than 100,000 people visit each of his
parts every year and despite no federal
regulations Arnold says safety is a top
priority launch covers their springs
this is woven in so the kids cannot hit
the springs with their feet and uses
redundant trampolines do all of your
trampolines have another trampoline
underneath every single one pit go says
a second layer of protection is helpful
but there are still risks if the top one
rips you've got a second one to hit the
problem is if the top one actually goes
far enough to hit the second one it
changes how the whole trampoline system
feels launch connects their trampolines
with a steel bar doctor Petco's research
says it can reduce energy transfer but
doesn't eliminate it over a five-year
period people reported more than 15,000
injuries at trampoline parks nationwide
and CBS News has confirmed at least six
deaths since 2012 experts believe that
cable and chain connections many parks
use are flawed what do you want
consumers to know based on your research
everybody in that system is
influencing everyone else's jump in the
upcoming months dr. pit Co is hoping to
publish the data he collected in a
sports medicine journal we asked Rob
Arnold they have launched could survive
if they took those forced arbitrations
out of their contracts which cuts down
on the legal action people can take
against the parks Arnold was confident
they could he also told us that he
supports federal regulation and would be
willing to work with lawmakers the owner
of launch I thought made good points to
say not all trampoline parts are created
equal
on the other hand when you listen to
what the doctor says it's very scary
does the doctor think that none of us
should use them so I don't see people
giving up trampolines right what he
basically says that this energy transfer
makes it so unpredictable I liked his
analogy when you're going down that
staircase and you don't you think you
missed a status I just did that and
you're like oh but yeah and they're Park
at launch they have these steel bars
that's supposed to reduce the energy
transfer but doctor Petco says it
doesn't eliminate it I go with my kids
regularly I'm in a there and what are
you thinking now mom are you what are
you thinking
well I always do things carefully a good
story yeah well that's also what's
important is if you know there's the
risk and you just everybody goes in
knowing it I think yeah probably the
problem there's a lot of people think oh
it's you know totally harmless fun I
fall I'll just bounce right back yeah
that's why I think this is important so
instead of the road double back I mean
stead of to double back talks I've just
been doing one sure yeah but just at
least as you know the risk a lot of us
you're right John I would never think
that it could be that dangerous Thank
You Meg good to have you at the table